ich bin recht orten ist mir eine freude
mit mister schwarz bönig mal in dieser
saison das ist meins tante betrifft wird
ein film für männer die ein bisschen
bauchansatz zu kämpfen haben und die
gerne auto frauen dabei musik hören
nicht ganz
ich liebe es du weißt schon dass töten
ganz viel zu es geht um zwei männer
leonardo dicaprio und eben und brad pitt
spielt den stuntman das dank jubel von
leonardo dicaprio der in fernsehserien
western serien vor allen dingen spielt
und so ein bisschen laufen absteigenden
ast ist was ihm zu großem selbstmitleid
verleite ich hab dich als schauspieler
engagiert nicht als fernsehkoch
du bist peinlich und das vor der
versammelten mannschaft gegen den dänen
den tarantino ja verehrt angeblich der
wird da zu einer asiatischen comicfigur
par excellence also weiß von was battle
abgesperrt zu sehen also eine wirkliche
eine karikatur sozusagen eines asiaten
in amerikas ist wirklich sehr sehr
unangenehm ist auch sehr für kritisiert
worden völlig zu recht
ich bin so entspannt habe ich kein kino
eigentlich und auch die beiden
hauptdarsteller schon lange nicht mehr
gesehen der größte schock ist eigentlich
so war es jedenfalls in den vorführungen
in denen ich war dass die leute um mich
rum offenbar alle darauf gewartet haben
wann gibt es endlich zermatschten
frauenköpfe und die gibt's halt am ende
und dann wird geklatscht und bild und
ich fand das ziemlich widerwärtig dieser
stoff kann sich alles immer einfach aber
tarantino liegt es ja darauf an
und das gehört zu den großen einwenden
die seit jahren gegen sein war kabel
diese ausbeuterische funktionen von
gewalt vor allen dingen gegen
frauenkörper die er ja also nahezu
zerfetzt
ich bin sharon tate ich bin in dem helm
sie sind da drin das bin ich ich bin mit
kerzen den tollpatsch
hat sie möchte ich was positives sagen
das positive ist nämlich dass er ja
tatsächlich auf 35mm zelluloid film
gedreht ist und alles was man sieht hat
auch tatsächlich stattgefunden das heißt
jedes plakat das dahin jede reklame lidl
will das leuchtschild von taco bell ist
tatsächlich da gewesen und nicht
hinterher ein gepixelt also es gibt
keine spezialeffekte im sinne von ca
[Musik]
er wird männern gefallen die sich eben
gerne zurücklehnen in eine zeit in der
vermeintlich noch so vieles ging was ihm
so gefiel also ihre eindeutige dominanz
war da was machen mit der hitze ist ein
flammenwerfer